tous les animaux du monde ont été
appelés à se réunir tout va bien se
passer on ne risque rien je dois vous
annoncer une chose affreuse le papa tous
regardent un homme très estimable nommé
noé construit une immense arche un
navire sur lequel nous attendrons la fin
du délai est ce que tu vas ça ne te
regarde pas cool
j'arrive à mon avis on n'a pas le droit
des classes les enfants risquent de se
noyer
on est enfermé ici je crois bien vous
retrouver vous au fond ce ne sont pas
nos enfants sur les hippopotames cette
année allons-y a laissé tomber deux
êtres très différents
vont devoir s'allier
tu m'as l'air d'avoir besoin d'un gros
câlin n'y pensent même pour échapper au
déluge impressionnante au chemin ils
vont découvrir qu'ils sont forcément là
bas allons récupérer nos enfants que
rien n'est impossible
quand on a un véritable ami voilà
grattez mondiale
oui oups les ratés l'arche la reine je
vais être asphyxiées pauvres ou cinéma
le 9 décembre